when it comes to jennifer lopez and ben
affleck is it 2002 or 2021
either way we love to see it feels
really good and it's really nice over
the weekend the reunited power couple
was seen celebrating jlo's 52nd birthday
casually hanging out together on a
luxurious yacht in france
check out jlo lying down enjoying the
view while ben
is enjoying another but benefer fans
couldn't help but notice that this
particular moment
looks way too familiar
yup that's jen and ben seemingly
recreating this iconic moment from the
music video for jlo's 2002 hit
jenny from the blog
let's see these moments side by side one
more time on the left
ben and jen in her 2002 music video and
on the right
ben and jen in 2021 living their best
lives
the duo also reached a relationship
milestone over the weekend jen and ben
made their relationship
instagram official with the triple
threat posting this steamy photo to her
feet
staying present in the moment and
enjoying all of the wonderful things
that are happening right now
the two previously dated back in 2002
and were even engaged before calling it
quits in 2004
and although jen hasn't publicly spoken
about their reconciliation
earlier this month she appeared on zane
lowe's apple music podcast
and made it clear that everything's all
good i love all the love
that's coming my way right now and all
of the
the good wishes and i just want
everybody to know that
it's the best time it's the best time of
my life and of course benefir seaside
rendezvous
didn't stop there fashion blogger rebel
nida tells e.t
j lo's b-day celebration went into the
night they were spotted enjoying dinner
at la
peja santa pay where the couple quote
looked very happy and were kissing
throughout the night and looked
super in love i think we had chemistry
as actors
from the first moment we started working
rebel goes on to say
ben and jlo felt very comfortable and
had the time of their life with the
crazy personal birthday show
that la peja put on for them they got a
lot of attention
but they seemed to love it aside from
having been on her arm
jen made it known that she was
definitely feeling herself on her big
day
showing off her fit physique in this
tic-tac video
give it to him
hello
[Music]
one thing is for sure 52 looks real good
on miss lopez and we still can't get
enough
of this boat side pda in 2002
[Music]
and in 2021